the tagline of this series is who do you
trust
so I want to play a little game a little
speed round of who in this group do you
trust
who do you trust to be the DJ for your
party
yeah
okay because I'll take you he there in
every way you know what I mean Sam will
Sam will be very lovable or you could go
with meals
who in this group do you trust to return
a call or a text quickly
often on Instagram or like boom boom
boom but that it's I've communicate more
and Sam on Instagram than probably
anybody okay so Sam everything yes twice
that's why if you if you've kind of gone
around
for everyone
okay who in this group do you
[Laughter]
trusting a yes who in this group do you
trust to flub their lines the most
you want to read the script well I'm
saying you want to look at it on the day
and then try and figure it out as you go
on yeah you do it you improve it with
what you want to say it makes it better
I wouldn't say improv's improve there we
go yeah and you know
don't worry about you know you're cute
when I stop talking
yeah
oh yeah right yeah I'll give you that
look you want Dynamic instead it's like
a helicopter I hear you here you go who
in this group do you trust to craft the
best cocktail or mocktail the restaurant
okay what is your what's your signature
what's your go-to I do love French
martini oh but it's not everybody's cup
of tea delicious
um
[Music]
Okay who in this group do you trust to
make up the best lie to bail you out of
a tough situation
is
[Music]
who in this group do you trust to have
the loosest lips and accidentally given
MCU secret away
Mark Ruffalo is not here
I'm gonna spoil a lake in the room
nobody everybody do it you don't do it
you just don't we don't leave like the
prince
this is just the beginning this is my
War alone I know you guys had a lot of
fun on set together he walks around with
a speaker imagine you're outdoor you're
Outdoors you're doing a big ass gun
fight and you know you're waiting for it
to start and all you're here
I don't know
that's it
the music is playing okay we're rolling
wow we're rolling we got everyone ready
and it's just on the back of us so
obviously we know there's no sound we
had it playing it was a sad moment no no
no we were there like yep
mew's always playing on set and the cast
wasn't against the little karaoke
session song of choice The Coasters
poison ivy
[Music]
know if you came on that's one of the
best moms I work in life you know oh you
gotta need emotion of the calamine
lotion
I sat there and sang and I sat right now
and Sam's like Sam's all across I'll
drop a whirl or two Sammy's bam-man
there's not a word now the place you
know what can you give me a rendition no
no no no no no no yeah yeah yeah you
know you've got the cash like we cost
no worries
man on the planet
Nick Fury is you know a tough nut to
crack is Samuel L Jackson that same
tough nut or is he just really a soft
y he's a soft day hey he's got him both
you can't look he's got them both he's
got them both you don't yeah the very
well modulated human and and evolved
over the many years and
Sam a long time and we've been in a lot
of different situations I think I can
speak for everyone here and everyone's
very excited when we get a chance to
work with Sam he creates such a fun
atmosphere on and off set and especially
in these really dark scenes that we
sometimes have to do together when when
someone yells cut it's just back to fun
and happiness one last fight did you
call him the loudest person you've ever
met yes
not to your face
well you did this morning I didn't say
anything I heard you I heard you say it
this morning it's kind of like really it
was so exciting because wait you could
just tell we were filming in a huge
house yes and normally you wouldn't know
a human had come in the front door you
know sort of 100 yards away but you
could just go I can you hear it here it
is
it is kind of like the Avengers
man we we make them look like amateurs
man they're cheap compared to us
Avengers are cheap compared to Scrolls
man
the six episode Thriller hits Disney
plus tomorrow newbies joining the Marvel
Universe include the Mother of Dragons
Emilia Clark Barbies Kingsley benedir
and Oscar winner Olivia Coleman who
plays a ruthless MI6 agent Olivia is it
true though that you would phone your
agent after every Marvel project and
said get me something in this Marvel
thing please
it's always always be polite even when
you're chopping off fingers
what was it that made you say I gotta
get in this universe
um I really enjoyed watching them all
and as uh uh now teenage boys when they
were little and we were watching we sort
of I think my husband and I started to
fall in love with the MCU through them
because it was they were excited to go
together it was an event and
and I am I do sort of feel everything
that I meant to feel in all films I'm
like the perfect audience member crime
jump or last night I was jumping every
time anything happened what's harder to
keep under wraps in MCU
um like plotline or the Barbie plot line
uh
I think I just ramble about like about
the thoughts I have about the characters
I never know how much that's given away
about the story or just like what I was
what sick things I was thinking about on
the day
um but yeah that's pretty easy
you're part of two projects that
everybody wants to know every single
thing about and you can't say anything
yeah I'm living in a camper van at the
moment west coast of Ireland so I
haven't seen anybody wait a minute is
this true you're living in a camper yeah
just for the next seven or eight weeks
it was something I was supposed to do
last year but that we didn't have the
time and like sometimes just popped up
so this is a little detour so nice it's
a detour for a couple of days I'm going
straight away oh okay so so basically I
haven't seen anyone to give away any
spoilers just be quiet sit in the back
and be quiet yeah